[Musik]
der äquator mit globetrotter darm
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wartet globetrotter punkt ch streamer
[Musik]
sechs uhr morgens in kenias massai mara
nationalpark für mary beginnt ihr
schultag die angehenden touristenführer
sollen lernen tierspuren zu lesen eines
von marys lieblingsfächern die tierwelt
fasziniert mich ich habe schon viel
gelernt ich kann erkennen welche tiere
trächtig sind und wann sie ihre jungen
zur welt bringen werden
und ich werde immer besser im spuren ist
das macht mich glücklich
jeder tag bringt mir neue interessante
dinge in der vergangenen folge haben die
amis letzte momente in ihrem dorf
miterlebt
inzwischen ist sie in die schule
zurückgekehrt
als einer der ganz wenigen masai frauen
hat sie die chance auf eine ausbildung
sie soll touristenführerin werden
in singapur strebt die ärztin und jetset
lady gaga die perfektion an bei ihrem
körper genauso wie bei ihren
mitarbeiterinnen
im pazifikstaat kiribati otto wien.at
katava erfahren dass ihr land untergehen
wird
vielleicht werden schon ihre enkelkinder
nicht mehr dort leben können
auf galapagos sind wir mit
touristenführer matthias espinosa
abgetaucht zu kreaturen der besonderen 8
die dritte folge beginnt mitten in den
weiten kenias
wir sind bereit für unserem gang in die
natur wenn ihr meine gäste wert würde
ich euch briefen bevor es losgeht wir
werden schauen was die tiere letzte
nacht gemacht haben das ist wie wenn man
am morgen auf facebook geht man schaut
nach was es neues gibt
wir schauen nach spuren von tieren und
nutzen dabei unsere sinne zum sehen
berühren hören schmecken spüren hier
haben wir einige spuren hier eine große
und da drüben nochmals das ist eine
große spur von wem könnte design einem
löwen gut warum ein löwe richtig wegen
der drei fußballen hinten und hier 14
ohne krallen hier haben wir noch eine
spur
und hier noch eine das ist ein löwe der
nicht auf jagd war schon bald soll auch
mary solche informationen an touristen
weitergeben bisher bedeuteten löwen für
sie vor allem gefahr für ihre kuhherde
löwen können lärm vermeiden wenn ein
löwe mit dem ersten fuß auf einen ast
tritt der bericht macht er beim zweiten
fuß keinen lärm er bei der austria
bereits gebrochen ist
als nächstes macht sich die gruppe auf
die suche nach dem ganz großen tieren
[Musik]
die galapagos aggressor ist einer der
luxuriösesten achten in die tierwelt von
galapagos einzutauchen 5000 franken
zahlen die touristen um eine woche lang
mit touristenführer matthias espinosa
die highlights der tierwelt von
galapagos zu sehen
[Musik]
matthias lebt vom tourismus
gleichzeitig ist er aber immer auch um
die tierwelt besorgt
das schiff nähert sich den tauchgebiet
matthias kümmert sich aber nicht nur um
seine touristen
möchte wissen wie es der hai bevölkerung
aus wolf geht weil wir hatten viele
jahre illegale fischerei hier wegen den
reifen lassen wie natürlich viel wird
sind in asiatischen ländern und die
kontrolle ist besser geworden und ich
möchte sehen wie ich der bevölkerung der
hammer und amboss eingeht
die suche nach den haien beginnt
aus dem blau taucht eine staffel makrele
auf
und dann die erste heim
[Musik]
ein weißspitzen rifai
wenig gefährlich
doch matthias zeigt bereits auf einen
weitaus unangenehmeren zeitgenossen
einen großen galapagos hi
[Musik]
vor ihm solle man sich in acht nehmen
hatte er vor dem tauchgang noch gewarnt
die taucher erregen das interesse des
hais
den haien niemals den rücken kehren
lautet matthias anweisung
immer näher kommen die haie
genau der kick den viele galapagos
touristen suchen
matthias versucht die haie im auge zu
behalten doch dann bricht er seine
eigene regel und wendet den haien den
rücken zu
[Musik]
immer sei mara nationalpark geht der
unterricht weiter
mary kann jetzt ihr geliebtes vogel buch
zum einsatz bringen
einige vögel machen interessante
geräusche weist es ein sport richtig
mary gehört zu den westen im kurs aber
die 20-jährige ist beschreiten und
drängt sich nicht in die erste reihe
wenn ihr hinter euch schaut seht ihr
einige kaputte bäume da seht ihr
gebrochene äste und einige zerkaute zwei
kindern wer war das
mister elefant und warum nicht misst er
die waffe greifen fressen nur die
blätter richtig nur die elefanten
brechen die erste ab die leute sagen
manchmal elefanten seien zerstörerisch
weil sie bäume fällen
wie seht ihr das der umgestürzte baum
dahinten wo das ist fressen für die
kleinen tiere die nicht klettern können
wenn ihr analysiert dann versucht immer
das große bild zu sehen dann seht ihr
auch die vorteile naturkunde und
philosophie kurs in einem
und jetzt steht für mary die erste
fahrstunde ihres lebens auf dem programm
[Musik]
auf galapagos hat matthias den
gefährlichen haien den rücken zugewendet
seine ganze aufmerksamkeit gilt einem
seil
es muss von menschenhand hierher
gebracht worden seien vermutlich von
illegalen fischern
ein plastik netz hat sich ebenfalls im
riff verfangen die spuren von
unterwasser wilderei gegen die matthias
ankämpft für viele fischarten werden
solche netze zur tödlichen falle
doch die illegale fischerei lässt sich
nur schwer kontrollieren
auf dem schiff verschafft matthias
seinem ärger luft
die plastik fischernetz material des
verbotenen gelassen
mit blei wird das dann ins wasser gelegt
und wasser gelassen und dann bleiben
natürlich viele heitere das heißt wir
haben noch probleme von illegaler
fischerei wir haben noch nicht gelöscht
und den prozent
jetzt muss es sich erstmal wieder um
seine touristen kümmern und die wollen
als nächstes zu den hammerhaien
[Musik]
auf kiribati youtube wiener theater war
gerade erfahren dass ihr land untergehen
wird
vielleicht werden bereits ihre enkel
gezwungen sein ihre heimat zu verlassen
mit diesem wissen muss jetzt umgehen
die umweltaktivistin claire hat ihr die
harten fakten vermittelt jetzt nimmt sie
youtube mit ans andere ende der insel
hier hat sich das meer besonders viel
land geholt gotovina wird von claire in
ein rettungs projekt für die insel
integriert die frauen pflanzen mangroven
ihre wurzeln sollen die erosion der
insel aufhalten
eine stunde lang arbeiten die frauen am
strand bei 40 grad im schatten
ich möchte etwas tun und meinem land zu
helfen
das ist anstrengend bei der hitze aber
wenn das eine möglichkeit ist unser land
vielleicht zu retten
dann würde ich das gerne machen schau
dass du immer drei setzlinge zusammen in
ein loch steckst dann haben wir immer
noch zwei weitere falls einer absterben
sollte das passiert oft dann schafft es
meistens mindestens einer der beiden
anderen claire arbeitet bereits seit
mehreren monaten an diesem projekt auf
dem wurzelgeflecht der mangroven ruht
die hoffnung eines ganzen volkes
natürlich ist das nur ein tropfen auf
den heißen stein
da mache ich mir nichts vor aber wir
möchten gerne zusammen etwas unternehmen
um unseren inseln zu helfen und das
machen wir mit den mitteln die wir haben
das wird den lauf der dinge nicht
verändern aber vielleicht zumindest ein
wenig herauszögern
genau das versucht auch der präsident
des landes
[Musik]
in singapur hat die ärztin georgia die
große pläne
[Musik]
seit vier jahren besitzt sie neben ihrer
schönheitsklinik auch eine eigene
kosmetiklinie mit ihren 34
mitarbeiterinnen und ihrem namen will
sie nichts weniger als den asiatischen
markt erobern
einmal mehr vollzieht georgia einen
wandel
die ärztin wird zur business frau und
strategien
[Musik]
von diesen verkaufsständen werden fünf
stück auf der theke stehen und
kosmetikprodukte die kommen woanders
händen mit perfektion und
selbstdisziplin hat sie sich
hochgearbeitet das verlangt sie auch von
ihren mitarbeiterinnen wenn ich die
leute ausbildet bin ich sehr streng
ich gebe schweiß und blut dafür
gleichzeitig sind mir langjährige
beziehungen sehr wichtig sie zum
beispiel arbeitet schon fast 13 jahren
ich musste mich mehr als ein jahr lang
und sie werden es brauche immer sehr
lange bis sie eine idee umsätze sagt
georgia aber wenn das konzept einmal
steht lässt sie das ziel nicht mehr aus
den augen
und dieses ziel ist alles andere als
bescheiden ich träume groß vielleicht
lachen die menschen über mich ich hoffe
dass sich diese produkte eines tages
sind vielen ländern verkaufen kann
ich möchte die sl oder asiens werden
und ich hoffe dass das team das mit mir
gestartet ist auch mit mir die früchte
aber auch eine george ali muss klein
anfangen bevor sie den asiatischen markt
erobern kann heißt es erstmal
kleinarbeit in der provinz
[Musik]
in caritas geht es derweil ums überleben
einer ganzen nation
während die frauen mangroven pflanzen
setzt sich der staatspräsident
persönlich für seine leute ein sein
arbeitssitz ist gerade mal so pompös wie
es die bescheidenen mittel des landes
erlauben
[Musik]
im vorzimmer des präsidenten gibt es nur
ein thema die folgen des klimawandels
präsident an otto ruft die welt zur
hilfe auf
seine mitarbeiter versuchen das
schicksal von carrie was weltweit auf
die agentin der mächtigen zu setzen
genau das macht auch der präsident
seit mehr als zehn jahren lenkt er die
geschicke seines volkes und fast genauso
lange ist er einer der hauptfiguren in
der debatte um den klimawandel
der präsident hat in england studiert
und die welt gesehen
die illusion einer rettung seines landes
hat er verloren
es ist eine tatsache
wir werden unser land verlassen müssen
wir werden uns eine neue heimat
das ist schwer auszusprechen
aber wir werden alle gehen müssen
das ist die realität
unser land wird untergehen natürlich
werden wir versuchen so lange wie
möglich ihr leben zu bleiben aber das
wird davon abhängen ob die
internationale gemeinschaft uns dabei
hilft was hier passiere stehe nicht nur
für kitas sondern für die welt als
ganzes
es geht hier um die werte der
menschlichkeit für welche werte stehen
was bedeutet uns wie es unserem nächsten
geht wir menschen weigern uns etwas
gegen den klimawandel zu unternehmen
ich denke was hier passiert ist eine
prüfung für die menschheit ich glaube
die wir hier handeln wird die weichen
stellen ob die menschen auf diesem
planeten überleben werden oder nicht
viele man rufen wir schon gepflanzt
haben
ja bis ans ende vom strand da hinten
weißt du was ich möchte dich gerne
mitnehmen auf die insel aber dort ist
ein ganzes dorf am meer versuchen heute
lebt dort niemand ich möchte dass du mit
eigenen augen siehst was der klimawandel
dort angerichtet hat
wird die turbine den schritt wagen in
der steppe kenias sind autofahrende
masai frauen so etwas wie ein weltwunder
und mary ist auf bestem wege ein solches
weltwunder zu werden
ihre erste fahrstunden als erstes musste
auf das pedal in der mitte treten das
ist die bremse die gangschaltung zuerst
nach links und dann nach oben schwierig
nicht so kräftig alles ganz locker
jetzt langsam mit dem rechten fuß aufs
gaspedal drücken und den anderen fuß
langsam lösen
und immer schön auf dem weg bleiben über
der fahrunterricht ist teil von marys
ausbildung später sollen dann auch
touristen ihren fahrkünsten vertrauen
für mary ist das eigentlich gar kein
problem zumindest mit zu kleiner hilfe
von links
und wie fühlst du dich zu lieben teil
wirklich gut
gut gemacht doch sicher ist sicher dass
wänden des chips übernimmt josef lieber
selbst auch wenn mary durchaus talent
hat ich bin fasziniert von dieser jungen
dame sie ist großartig
unglaublich ich bin glücklich dass sie
fahren kann
sie kann ich sag's euch wenn ich jetzt
krank würde sie würde uns einfach josef
bringt den wagen position denn jetzt
will mary mehr gas geben
[Musik]
juli ist ausnahmsweise mal zu fuß
unterwegs und für sie noch schlimmer in
der prallen äquator sonne
wenn ich brauche werde verkauft sich
meine haut gleichung scream nicht gut
das hier ist das neue einkaufszentrum da
drüben wird nur zwischen diesen
stationen gibt es immer eine menge leute
hier entsteht ein wohnquartier am
stadtrand von singapur
da wäre georgia mit einer boutique dabei
sein das hier wird einer der
haupteingänge sein
in der musik hier müssen wir gute
verkäufer ansetzen sie müssen perfekt
zweisprachig sein denn hier leben viele
chinesen georgia ließ analyse
die leute haben immer weniger zeit in
der innenstadt einkaufen zu gehen
deshalb würden die vororte immer
wichtiger ein markt von zehntausenden
potenziellen käufer
[Applaus]
zusammen mit ihrer langjährigen
persönlichen mitarbeiter in evelyn
entwickelt george ali die strategien
unsere marketing-strategie für die
kosmetikprodukte hier draußen wird sein
dass wir uns während der woche nach den
berufstätigen ausrichten und an den
wochenenden nachdem familie
was sie noch nicht weiß sie bekommt
unterstützung von prominenter seite
[Musik]
anders als george möchte mary unbedingt
selbst fahren und jetzt wieder links
oben in den ersten gang jetzt gas geben
aber immer schön langsam jetzt langsam
runter von der kupplung
und er
jetzt könnte den fuss vom anderen vidal
der und immer schön auf den weg schauen
am steuer eröffnen sich für mary neue
welten
da kommt man schon mal auf ideen kann
nicht mehr richtig gas geben und abhauen
nicht übermütig werden
doch marie scheint sich bereits
auszumalen wohin sie mit dem auto
abbauen könnte wenn nicht ihr fahrlehrer
neben ihr saß
ist doch super dass du fahren kannst
oder ja das ist toll
nur schade dass es so schnell vorbei ist
das war herrlich
mir fehlen die worte
er hätte nicht gedacht dass ich das
schaffen
es ist gut wenn man selbstvertrauen hat
eines tages werde ich alleine fahren wie
die männer nur ich und die maschine so
wir wechseln steigen
lasst mich noch mal fahren nur bis zur
schule neuen gewürzt doch in einen baum
fahren
und so entwickelt sich die schüchternen
mary durch ihre ausbildung schritt für
schritt zu einer selbstbewussten frau
[Musik]
auf caritas hat sich jutta biener
entschieden die erste große reise ihres
lebens anzutreten
das trage ich gerne ihre tochter soll in
der zwischenzeit die verantwortung
übernehmen
ich muss gleich los nach aber ja was
willst du dort machen
ich möchte mit eigenen augen sehen was
dort passiert ist
bringst du uns von dort bau wurzeln
vor allem möchte ich sehen wie dort die
situation ist deshalb drei sicher dahin
ich bin sehr gespannt darauf zu sehen
was in dem dorf passiert ist immerhin
war das ja genauso end of me und
gleichzeitig bin ich sehr traurig meine
familie zurück zu lassen auch wenn es
nur ein paar tage
wir machen sonst
und jetzt werden wir zum ersten mal
länger als einen tag voneinander
getrennt sein
also wenn dir mach keinen mist hier
passt gut auf euch auf
[Musik]
asiens zukunft sieht gut aus
der kontinent ist wirtschaftlich
gewachsen singapur ist das beste
beispiel dafür dass neue asiatische
selbstbewusstsein zeigt sich auch in der
modewelt für george ali das letzte
meeting an diesem tag und eine dicke
überraschung
der geschäftsführer der asiatischen mode
vereinigung macht ihr die aufwartung
[Musik]
die gespräche mit studenten aus japan
korea china aus paris london und new
york
sie sind alle großartig aber die
asiatischen studenten wollen nicht in
asien bleiben
sie wollen nach new york paris und
london und die studenten aus new york
paris und london wollen nicht nach asien
die wollen in europa bleiben das muss
sich ändern
und da kommt georgia ins spiel
sie gilt als stil-ikone in singapur und
als solche soll sie asien im namen der
vereinigung international vertreten
ich will jetzt hier nicht auf bescheiden
machen aber ich könnte mir da schon noch
ein paar andere vorstellen
natürlich freue ich mich
das ist eine egoistische war
hier geht es nicht um freundschaft es
geht um glaubwürdigkeit
ich fühle mich sehr geehrt wirklich und
ich bin sehr stolz dass sie und ihr team
hier auf die beine stellen
ich bin überzeugt das klappt mit ihrem
neuen titel ist georgi ihrem ziel die
stl oder asiens zu werden bereits einen
kleinen schritten hergekommen
[Musik]
auf galapagos ist der bogen von darwin
das mekka aller fans von hammerhaien
der hammerhai kann sich beim liebesakt
nicht am weibchen festhalten
also muss er sich an ihr festbeißen
matthias bereitet seine gäste auf ihren
tauchgang vor
denn dies ist der absolute höhepunkt der
reise und gleichzeitig ihr ende
einmal ist ein hammer wieder nach bis
auf 924 meter tiefe getaucht unter
wasser lassen die gefürchteten haie
nicht lange auf sich warten
zunächst noch eine art vorhut doch dann
eine ganze schule von hammerhaien
bis zu vier meter lang können diese haie
werden auch sie gelten als potenziell
gefährlich
[Musik]
immer näher kommen sie an die taucher
hatten
für solche momente reisen die touristen
um die halbe welt bis nach galapagos
es gibt nur wenige orte auf der welt an
denen sich diese faszinierenden
kreaturen aus solcher nähe beobachten
lassen
[Musik]
die touristen haben bekommen wonach sie
gesucht haben
die galapagos aggressor kann sich auf
den rückweg machen
matthias kunden werden von ihren
erlebnissen schweren so werden dank ihm
noch mehr menschen in die tierwelt
eindringen
die er eigentlich schützen will mit
diesem spagat muss erleben das gute vom
tourismus ist dass die leute ist sehr
viel geld bezahlen um diese hammerhaie
hier zu sehen und dieses schöne unter
wasser natur und das hilft natürlich den
ganzen nationalpark zu erhalten
die unkosten zu bezahlen und auch
galabau guss zu schützen
aber dieser dieses gleichgewicht
zwischen zu viel oder zu wenig tourismus
ist eine keine einfache sache
es gibt natürlich immer mehr druck dass
mehr touristen kommen wollen und
irgendwo irgendwann muss man sagen so so
viele leute und das geht nicht mehr
weiter
doch ob dieser moment jemals kommen wird
der trend geht eher in die andere
richtung
während die natur noch einmal eine
bilderbuch kulisse auffährt
verabschiedet sich matthias von seinen
gästen
wir haben wunderbare dinge gesehen
auch wird die sicht nicht immer antwort
wir haben große schwärme von barracuda
grund sein mag rennen gesehen
es war ein großartiger tritt
ich hoffe er kommt bald zu diesem
schönen fleckchen erde zurück
[Musik]
und so verabschieden auch wir uns von
matthias espinosa und den bildern der
gewaltigen natur von galapagos
[Musik]
von einem menschen der sich immer wieder
dafür einsetzt dass das fragile
gleichgewicht zwischen tourismus und
natur erhalten bleibt
dafür tauchen wir auf dem äquator ein in
eine neue geschichte
am anderen ende der welt in borneo sie
beginnt in der provinzstadt miri
es ist die geschichte von lupen einen
weiteren kämpfer für die natur
supermärkte gehören eigentlich nicht zu
seinem leben denn nun ist im dschungel
aufgewachsen
er gehört zu den pennern einem der
urvölker malaysias und einkaufen tut er
nur weil er eine expedition plant
[Musik]
lupus reise führt in den regenwald in
seine heimat
eine reise die mehrere tage dauert
in seinen stammesgebiet will er gegen
die abholzung der wälder kämpfen
mit dabei sind mehrere mitglieder seines
volkes
auf dem weg kommen ihnen bereits
dutzende lastwagen mit gefällten tropen
bäumen entgegen
genau aus der region in die lupen
unterwegs ist nun hat sich in den
letzten jahren zu einem stammesführer
entwickelt und setzt sich für das
überleben seines volkes ein
wenn ich all die lastwagen sehr beladen
mit den bäumen aus unserem urwald dann
habe ich das gefühl die holzfäller töten
unsere verwandten und schaffen so lag
das macht mich sehr traurig oder urwald
können wir doch nicht leben
für die pin an hat sich schon bruno
manser eingesetzt bis er im dschungel
spurlos verschwand
dieser menschen wären wehrlos gebe es
nicht kämpfer wie bruno manser oder
lupen
wer lang bot geht es immer tiefer in den
dschungel
[Musik]
die penan sind ein urvolk sie leben mit
der natur und kennen sich aus mit
pflanzen
deshalb bringt unser übersetzer james
einer kranken frau bei einem
zwischenstopp blätter die er für sie
gesammelt hat medizin die sie benötigt
zweimal pro tag als tee trinken
danke vielen dank
james ist überzeugt diese pflanzen
werden der frau helfen
ich habe vor vier monaten meiner
schwester solche blätter gegeben sie
hatte lungenkrebs und die ärzte sagten
sie werde als stabil
dann habe ich im urwald solche blätter
für sie gesucht und tee daraus gemacht
meine schwester hat jeden tag drei
deziliter davon getrunken
jetzt geht es ihr besser sie ist nicht
gestorben
nun ist 38 und mit seinen eltern als
nomade aufgewachsen
die meisten pannen sind inzwischen
sesshaft und lebenden dörfern tief im
regenwald
die bulls expedition geht nun zu fuß
weiter er kann es gar nicht abwarten
endlich sind wir richtig im urwald in
den nächsten tagen werden wir das leben
der nomaden im dschungel leben im
einklang mit allen anderen lebewesen im
urwald ganz nach der tradition unserer
vorfahren
[Musik]
laut ban an volk gehört dieser teil des
urwaldes ihnen doch das sieht die
regierung anders sie will ihn abholzen
lassen
das ziel von lupus expedition ist zu
zeigen dass der staat kein recht dazu
hat in wenigen stunden wird das dunkle
nacht sein
zeit für ihn und seine leute das
nachtlager zu bauen
der urwald bietet hierfür alles was man
braucht
[Musik]
das wissen über das leben mit der natur
ist den bernern seit generationen von
den älteren weitergegeben worden
[Musik]
der urwald hat uns disziplin er lehrt
uns unsere kultur der urwald war immer
unser leben wir reparieren die regel des
waldes und folgenden machen wir das
nicht dann werden wir krank können
bekommen probleme und gehen verloren
[Musik]
morgen soll die eigentliche mission
beginnen
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge werden wir
erfahren wie lupen und seine freunde für
das überleben seines volkes kämpfen
george ali macht sich auf mit ihren
produkten das nachbarland thailand zu
erobern
in kenia geht mary auf tuchfühlung mit
großen tieren und aufklebers macht jutta
biener die erste reise ihres lebens und
sieht dabei in ihre eigene zukunft
[Musik]
dies und mehr in der nächsten folge von
der äquator
breitengrad der extreme
der äquator mit globetrotter darm
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wert wie globetrotter punkt ch